hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the things nice I know you
were all issued for me to go down this
well so here we go oh yeah down well
into the darkness all right Oh level
transition are all the citizens really
dead
maybe I can find someone in the village
and know that my brother is a lad what
the hell is this stuff I need to watch
it down here okay oh oh wait that's not
regular coop hahaha what is this oh no
oh my I fell screaming through the alien
cityscape clenching the stone key now I
stand with the brothers these are hard
to read my blood already boils for
justice you had no right you got no
right to Justine oh I've read these
before actually with um back in another
mod I can't remember which one but holy
hell
this has got to be custom holy enough
there's a balls eyeballs there were no
eyeballs before I don't remember any
balls but oh don't look don't like shut
up oh who is that what is going on
oh man okay what's this looks like
pieces of the orb that I picked up one
while ago okay
I could hear something calling to be
down in this well a voice calling to me
telling me to come down to it so I
decide to make a ladder took me two
weeks but I was able to get down to the
bottom of the well I can't believe that
some sort of old ruins lie down here the
power is so great that it pulled me
right to the orb in the room and I could
hear it talking to me
I've seen some sort of monster or alien
alike being on the floor but it's likely
they're dying off for losing power the
note goes on to tell about the great
power can give him and make him a king
in this world in other worlds as well
but for that to happen he has to break
the orb and let out all the power the
rest of the note is too damaged for me
to read okie-dokie is a key ah that
might be the key to the door up yonder
woman I got a new
it looked like someone has smashed the
orb and not even one of the pieces is
glowing I need to find one with some
life left in it
I'll have to look around some more Hey
no one oh I don't want go this is very
cool what am i this one's glowing that's
got creepy excellent okey dokey
that's the letter L see doorways oh
thank out this Americans look at that I
mean he did that with what was there
that's amazing but I do not remember
there being eyeballs yeah oh wait here
we go let's jump in I think I'll take
the ladder thank you very much oh okay
oh no oh no oh oh no jump scares please
don't no jumps here no please oh that
looks blocked I'll go it that way
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no oh okay I wasn't really a
junker oh my ah this guy is awesome
look at this look at this [ __ ] man at
first I was curious why this was so
highly rated but now I see this is
incredible what he's done
is that there there it's something
glowing that's what I need should be
careful when I take this powerful item
uh-huh oh oh they're on fire can't see
me oh my god what do I do
aah what is that oh oh those are the
both of the monsters from Black Plague
Oh what do I do
holy aah do I go around him do a jump up
here ah yeah totes totes what I do get
out of here oh [ __ ] off
okay what is this man what's going on
here okay I don't know what the deal is
I don't know where they plenty oh [ __ ]
that right there
gah okay anyway um I'm doing I'm just
gonna run for I'm just gonna run for it
[ __ ] it
ah why do I have to hurt myself
okay they can't follow me in here I'm
cool I'm cool I'm cool I'm cool uncle go
away man eff off huh I don't need that
screaming in my ear
no jump-scares no whammies no whammies
Oh
oh it sounds like I woke up something I
shouldn't I have to run and jump to the
ladder
I fell on Jim dr. Rick letter wiggler
wiggler right there just hahahaha oh
don't break don't break don't break
laughter laughter don't break don't
break don't do oh I want to get here oh
I want to go oh don't break okay thank
you thank you
what the hell is my father let into this
world I must stop his plans oh I didn't
like that place man and I can't believe
he made so much that incredibly detailed
the place for just you know of just that
quick venture into the man
okay that sounds like an actual monster
look seriously it sounds like there are
more I hear a lot of vitals okay four
cool
we are hardly ladies I got this
all right now aha how did Jay get into
his house then I mean come on come on I
mean really
really
oh hello oh it's body part exploding
your apples look a little like they suck
hi Jay Jay Jay pretty embarrassed you
guys naked aren't you aren't you
isn't it so strange that everyone who
dies in amnesia dies completely naked
even even Alexander he was completely
naked when he died whoops I didn't mean
to do that I meant to grab this cuz I
thought mine I mean to do that
it don't matter
not many reasons tap tinderboxes anyway
another dead guy Fantasmic oh just what
I need I'll see you back there
cuckoos yeah like those crucifixes help
Jim oh here's some tinderboxes I would
have one more sugar claudette tinderbox
they're giving me tinderbox it must be
for a reason okay no time everyone is
dead my family is gone and I've only
managed to hide for this long but I can
feel them getting close to me I won't
let myself become one of those things in
the night it's killing everyone hey
things are the night that's how it all
started slowly killing one at a time
every night thinking that numbers
increase so I'll kill myself if anyone
finds us no police chopping into pieces
so they can't turn me into one of them
that's my last wish and then run fast
and don't ever look back
so I got to chop this guy's head off a
child
yeah
little grody
and more okay gonna gonna do more ah
alright the head of a villager good good
good job good job me oh man left leather
leather
bird
hmm
I wonder if I'm going to be chased
looks clear so far okay I really thought
something was gonna chase me into the
other other level there I guess it's not
too late for that to happen okay okay
okay
okay we're okay we're cool cool yeah
we're cool oh okay now can finally make
some progress I mean we've been making
progress all the time it's just that
they've had a lot of stuff to do in this
place there's a lot of going back and
forth really in-depth notes and all
sorts of like that really cool I got
nothing wrong oh hello baby did you miss
me oh I bet you did oh hello darling
Oh how's your twin over there I'm sorry
I got to go into another dimension I
know I know you miss oh you're triplets
oh that's so glorious but I gotta go I
gotta go I gotta go conquer some castle
someone gotta go important business you
know how it is all right let me read the
note because the specific order some
kind of artifact second object place on
the pedestal body and then blood of my
own okay all right so here's where the
artifact goes free and then the head
perfectly normal oh yeah that looks good
and then some of my own blood oh well
now hahaha no what's up don't say
anything
oh there they are okay bye bye bye bye
bye bye I said bye bye get out of here
they were pretty far behind to get me
they progress was my three girls slowed
him up
okay enough with the music okay enough
we in the castle now I thought it was
gonna transport me to some other world
well this looks a bit otherworldly but
oh hello Justine how you doing
but I'll go grab your books
ooh like dominoes food all right that's
enough
goofing around our little market for huh
nah nothing okay sure Oh what do we have
here here you don't belong here
where am I and what are you fin is on my
name you can't even begin to understand
what I am but I think I'll let you go
for now My servants will take care of
you
wait father is that you you look so
different
what have you done to mother where is my
brother father
oh wow it was looking so nice why you
have to go screw it up or everything up
taller I got a little pause word okay
maybe the brother got corrupted instead
maybe the thought manikin maybe the
father is not the one okay that's good
chairs what are you doing
defend me a big pulsating glob Oh
watching McCauley all right I'm over
here up no I am actually out of time for
this episode so thank you all oh my god
I get it I get it I get it
don't stand in the goo I get it all
right thank you all so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye